so let's talk about some of the fun
stuff your performance from the snake
scene
beginning of the the movie too what will
become iconic kissing between you and
and Brad Pitt when you say you are so
funny you know and the whole audience
goes you know that was improvised that
wasn't in the script but I thought when
else am I going to get the chance to
kiss Brad Pitt I'm just gonna go for it
yeah okay well then let me go there what
was that like for you it was it's great
Damien Damien I said Damien I think
Nelly would just go up and kiss Jack and
she and Damon was like
um I think she well she could wait hold
on you you just want to kiss Brad Pitt
and I was like oh so sue me I might this
opportunity might never come up again
you're right though and he was like and
it does work for the character I was
like I think so and so then I did it the
first time and then we finished that
take and I was like thanks Damian and he
was like no do it again that really
works I was like
[ __ ] yeah